direction maintenant le centre-ville
d'orléans où je pars rejoindre l'atelier
de rémi pierre et dominique ces artisans
facteur de flûte traversière perpétue le
savoir faire traditionnel en fabriquant
entièrement à la main cet instrument de
musique d'exception vous entendez je
crois qu on arrivé là là quelle ambiance
studieuse
bonjour madame je suis contente de vous
voir
waaa donc la voici ça c'est la fameuse
flûte traversière par mais non voilà je
suis ravi parce que il n'a plus
quasiment plus des fabricants de de
flûte traversière en france est
effectivement on est l'un des derniers
ateliers il reste deux ateliers en
france nous et un autre atelier à paris
c'est quasiment un établi de bijoutiers
de joaillier pensons que healy et même
des fresques centre de douai déjà
exactement on utilise un petit peu les
mêmes coûts alors je vais te donner à
tablier et voilà je suis prête
on commence par quoi alors je vais
t'emmener mois dans la pièce juste à
côté
elle a vécu cette machine c'est une
machine effectivement qu'a vécu qui a
été complètement modifiée par monsieur
parme non parce que on peut pas acheter
une machine pour fabriquer des flûtes
dans le commerce là maintenant on veut
vraiment pouvoir faire les notes donc il
faut qu'on ouvre complètement les trous
je m'installe je vérifie que je suis
bien placé je démarre la machine une
fois que je suis inséré
on a ouvert notre fille te propose de
faire la suivante je démarre et tu
descends et voilà des mois on pourra
maintenant jouer un deux pièces sur 7,8
des parents étaient dans l'univers de la
musique tu as grandi dans cet univers là
j'ai fait des études de musique
oui la musique elle a toujours été
présente à la maison très tôt tu as su
que tu m'aies travailler dans cet
univers j'ai toujours adoré la musique
j'ai toujours adoré les métiers manuels
quand on combine les deux on se retrouve
dans un atelier comme celui ci est tué
spécifiquement celui là celui de
monsieur permanente pour moi le but
c'était de venir travailler ici et il
m'a refusé plusieurs fois dans mes
demandes d'apprentissage et il était
d'ailleurs très bien j'ai pu voir
d'autres ateliers d'autres instruments
et à la fin de mes quatre années de
formation il a accepté enfin de me
prendre et donc une aujourd'hui c'est
toi qui assurent la relève
voilà avec pierre et dominique ce qui
m'épate ici c'est de voir votre jeune
âge vous êtes tout jeune à reprendre ce
savoir faire qu'elle savoir faire
ancestral et touahri mythe a été le
premier à intégrer cet atelier oui alors
je suis arrivé il ya un peu plus de dix
ans en fait on a fait notre
apprentissage ensemble avec pierre
pendant quatre ans donc à l'institut
technologique européen des métiers de la
musique et au mans on vous êtes
rencontrés sur les bancs d'école
exactement voilà et dominique nous avons
joint alors donc ce que je vais te
demander de faire c'est de faire la même
chose que moi de fraiser cette petite
pièce là donc je vais te préparer ça
comme si jamais j'en laisse trop de
matière
t'inquiète pas je vais surveiller tu vas
mettre la petite fraise plate
tu vois je comprends mieux le parallèle
avec le monde de l'horlogerie et toutes
ces petites pourraient tout à fait c'est
ce même type d'outils comme ça attention
las comme ça c'est comme ça et là il
faut appuyer quand même assez fermement
vers la gauche voilà bien et voilà ça me
semble pas mal
alors ouais c'est très bon en général
c'est les mêmes artisans qui travaillent
sur le la flûte de a à z
c'est un peu la particularité de notre
atelier c'est qu'on est compétent sur
toutes les étapes voilà ça va on y tient
je peux vous dire que tout est fait à la
main vous en avez la preuve c'est
vraiment du fait main oui on comprend
que vous avez le label entreprise du
patrimoine vivant et ensuite une fois
qu'on a fini ça qu'elle est quelle est
l'étape suivante alors l'étape suivante
ça va être la finition je vais te
laisser laisser voir ça avec dominique
avec l'apprenti et dominique qui a
rejoint le binôme pierres et mis au jour
dominique la dernière chose à faire en
fait c'est de vérifier qu'elle bouge
bien qu'elle bushmills bouche bien en
fait qu'elle soit bien étanche que quand
vous fermez clé bas la note se
produisent bien parce que la cheminée a
bien fermé
alors comment tu vérifies que les sons
sortent bien alors ça c'est avec des
bouts de papier à cigarette
je le vérifie avec mon papier si sur
tout le tour de la clé du tampon c'est
bien fermé ça c'est intrigant a quand
même rare du couquet en quoi tu vois que
c'est par exemple mal bouché
et bien c'est à la pression du papier
donc là c'est ouvert j'ai fait en sur le
papier je tire et je vois si ya la même
force partout c'est une invention maison
où tous les artisans qui sait ce qu'on
apprend même à l'école du camp oui oui
je me souviens la première fois j'ai
pleuré parce que c'est difficile c'est
d'essayer
oui je vais faire attention sur la zéro
défaut avec celui-là donc tu le mets
comme ça oui et après tu vois que ça
pèse oui ça pince et c'est derrière
essai
la l'opposé oui c'est pense pas trop à
ça pèse pas trop donc c'est pas bon de
zepa mans et donc est ce que tu fais là
bas voilà on veut reprendre la flûte et
on va l'améliorer ce petit défaut
toi t'as apprentis ici l'ontt appris le
métier avec pierre et me voilà oui oui
donc je suis je passe deux tiers de mon
temps ici un tiers à l'école l'item ou
pierre et rémy sont aussi professeur non
sélective et croise en cours et puis à
l'atelier
j'avais tranquille dit petit accent
oui oui tout à fait j'ai dû québec mais
du coup tu es venu alors nous on pourra
prendre sa part fait je suis venu à
orléans parce que je voulais travailler
chez par maintenant cesser
la référence pour moi la référence pour
tout dire j'ai fait une demande de stage
ici sans trop y croire
eh ben ils ont bien de la chance de
t'avoir parce que vraiment tu fais du
bon travail mais vous savez quoi c'est
bien beau doigt la fabrication de flûte
mais je crois que j'ai quand même mérité
de l'entendre le leçons de cette fuite
qu'est ce que vous en dites
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez déjà eu des demandes
extravagantes ou très particulière en
termes de fabrication de fuite on a eu
des choses assez assez folle oui des
flûtes de gauche etc ont été étendues
avec des brevets qu'on a déposé
même des innovations qu'ont apporté en
plus qui n'existaient pas qu'on n'a même
pas brevetées tellement sale et c'était
des pièces uniques
donc on innove dans ces secteurs c'est
ce que nous permet notre pays
ces deux raids de faire des commandes de
répondre à des commandes un peu spécial
qui sortent un petit peu de la grande
série moi je dis bravo à tous les trois
quarts grâce à me masser savoir-faire il
encore de beaux jours devant lui grâce à
l'esprit d'équipé qui anime de trois
compagnons je leur souhaite de tout
coeur de continuer de développer leur
activité et de former comme dominique de
futurs passionnés
[Musique]